your original contrast and you were
actually wearing it now look at that I
am wearing it right now this is on some
guy met on spring break he lives in Long
Island I have no idea who he is Bob from
longisland forget about it well Bob from
Long Island may be long gone but Jenny's
bringing back the dress and the big hair
for a prom date with husband Donnie
Wahlberg in the middle of New York's
herald square what do you guys remember
most about your prom night um for me it
was that I didn't enjoy my prom very
much yo new kid on the block song the
hot chef in some not a TV song Don equal
to yours I went to a prom it was not
mine and I was very sad too i knew i was
with the wrong date and I was hoping one
day to be with the right date at a
problem and I think today it's actually
coming soon and now these two were
helping couples get in the mood for the
big dance by launching SiriusXM's a new
limited run prom radio you can tune in
Friday to relive all the memories good
and bad i didn't get one compliment on
this dress from any of my friends now i
know why it's because everyone tells me
it's actually ugly it actually fits
better now than it did then just a limb
bot boon yeah the boobs are a little
fuller ok little perkier little first
Bob you missed out on the good boob
buddy sorry